FIREARMS.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE IS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT TO TELL
US WHAT HAS CHANGED.
>> I AM SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS PUSHING FORWARD ON
THINGS THAT WE KNOW HAVE
BROAD-BASED SUPPORT AND THAT WE
CAN IMMEDIATELY GET DONE.
>> COLLECT THE ART OF THE
POSSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN TO IMPROVE
SCHOOL SAFETY IN THE WAKE OF OAK
PARK SWORD SHOOTING FALLS WELL
SHORT OF HIS CRITICS SAY OF HIS
OWN RHETORIC.
>> THIS IS NOT A POPULAR THING
IN TERMS OF THE NRA.
I'M GOING TO SAY IT ANYWAY.
THINK OF IT.
YOU CAN BUY A HANDGUN.
YOU CAN'T BUY 1:30 HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL YOU'RE 21 BUT YOU CAN BUY
THE KIND OF WEAPON USED IN THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING AT 18.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS THINKING
ABOUT STUDYING RAISING THE AGE
OF BUY LONG GUNS TO 21, AUDITING
THE FBI TO PLAN, ESTABLISHING
RIGOROUS FIREARMS TRAINING FOR
QUALIFIED TEACHERS AND EXPANDING
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
NO MENTION OF RAISING THE AGE TO
BUY WEAPONS LIKE THE AR-15.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS CALL THE
PLAN A MUCH-NEEDED FIRST AVENUE.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE BEST
WAY FORWARD TO PUSH THESE OTHER
THINGS THROUGH, WHETHER IT'S ON
A STATE LEVEL, WHETHER IT'S ON A
FEDERAL LEVEL.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE EFFORT TO
TREAT SCHOOL SAFETY THE WAVE AS
BANKS AND AIRPORTS WILL BE
STUDIED BY FEDERAL COMMISSION
HEADED BY EDUCATION
SECRETARY BETSY DeVOS.
IT'S BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS ON
THE TABLE.
PART OF THE JOB OF THE
COMMISSION WILL BE TO STUDY IT
AND SEE IF IT WILL BE ADVANCED
AS A RECOMMENDATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID AS MUCH ON
TWITTER, NOTING THAT THINGS ARE
MOVING RAPIDLY BUT NOT MUCH
POLITICAL SUPPORT, TO PUT IT
MILDLY.
ADAM SCHIFF STRONGLY DISAGREES.
"ACTUALLY, MR. PRESIDENT,
THERE'S OVERWHELMING POLITICAL
SUPPORT FOR GUN SAFETY REFORM
INCLUDING AGE LIMITS, UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS, AND AN
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN.
LIKE YOU SAID, TOO MANY
REPUBLICANS ARE SCARED OF THE
NRA, INCLUDING, PLAINLY, YOU."
A BARRAGE OF CRITICISM AIMED AT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR NOT DOING MORE.
POLITICS ONCE AGAIN.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS CALLING ON
STATES TO PASS SO-CALLED RPOs.
RISK PROTECTION ORDERS FOR WHAT
THEY DO IS ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO REMOVE THEIR FIREARMS FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO PREVIOUSLY